The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
BOGDAN FEDELES:
Hi, welcome back.
I am Dr. Bogdan Fedeles.
Let's solve some more
biochemistry problems.
Today we're going to be talking
about problem 3 of problem set
10.
Now this is a problem about the
spontaneity of gluconeogenesis.
As you guys have
already learned,
gluconeogenesis is the process
by which non-sugar precursors
are used to produce glucose.
This problem should
help you think
of the following
conundrum-- in a cell,
when we have glucose we can
make energy by doing glycolysis.
But at the same
time, the cell can
take, for example, the endpoints
of glycolysis such as pyruvate,
or even further metabolites
like amino acids,
and use the pathway in
reverse to make glucose.
Now if one process
is spontaneous
in terms of
thermodynamics, then how
could we run the
reaction in reverse?
So here we're
going to be looking
at a couple of steps
of gluconeogenesis that
are the exact reverse
of the reactions
that you've seen
already in glycolysis.
And then in the end,
we're going to be talking
about the whole pathway
level and make some comments
on the spontaneity of both
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis.
Part A of the problem deals
with the aldolase reaction,
namely going from
fructose 1,6 bisphosphate
to glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
dihydroxyacetone phosphate.
Now in gluconeogenesis, we will
be going in reverse, starting
with dihydroxyacetone
phosphate and glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate to regenerate
fructose 1,6 bisphosphate.
Let's take a look
at the reaction.
This is dihydroxyacetone
phosphate.
This is glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate or GAP.
And these two come together
in the aldolase reaction
to form fructose 1,6
bisphosphate, or F 1,6 BP.
Now the Part 1 of
the question asked
us to write down the detailed
mechanism for this reaction,
running in reverse.
So as you guys know, aldolase,
specifically the Class II
aldolases, use an active
site lysine residue
to covalently bind
the substrates
during the course
of the reaction.
So this reaction will proceed
by dihydroxyacetone phosphate
binding to the active site
lysine of the aldolase.
Here we have the
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
and the lysine in
the active site.
So as a first step
to the mechanism,
the lysine is going to
react as the carbonyl group
in the dihydroxyacetone
phosphate
to form a Schiff's
base, or an imine.
As you can imagine,
the reaction is
going to be catalyzed
by a general base, which
is going to remove
one of the protons
from the lysine, which then
becomes a good nucleophile
and can attack the carbonyl.
Which can then will be
protonated by a general acid.
So this way you obtain an
intermediate as shown here,
which can then lose
the water molecule
to form the Schiff base.
Once again, we need a base
that will take this proton
and then the water will need
another acid molecule to leave.
So what we have
formed here, this
is the protonated Schiff base,
or what we call an iminium ion.
And if you look at it
from the point of view
of where we started from,
which was a carbonyl group,
this is a version of
an activated carbonyl.
A carbonyl that would it's
now poised to do chemistry.
Once again, this
is a iminium ion.
Now as we talked in
the carbonyl video,
iminium ions are
activated carbonyls
that can now undergo some
of the carbonyl reactions
with more ease.
For example, this one is
going to do an enolization.
So we have highlighted
here the alpha hydrogen
next to the carbonyl group.
So we're going to form
the enol by removing
this hydrogen, and the carbonyl
with its positive charge
on the nitrogen, so it's at
a very good electron sync.
So what we're forming
here is an imine
that's bound to a double bond.
So this we're going
to call an enamine.
So now this is the
reactive version
of the dihydroxyacetone
phosphate.
Now it's poised to react
with the other partner
in the reaction, GAP-
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate,
which we've shown here.
Now GAP is going to be the
carbonyl component of this aldo
reaction, while the enamine from
the dihydroxyacetone phosphate
is going to be the
enolic component.
So the enol is going to
be a very good nucleophile
and is going to
attack the carbonyl.
The reaction is once again
initiated by this amine group.
The electrons move here and
this attacks the carbonyl.
And we can protonate
it with a general acid.
So what we obtain here
is now a molecule that
has from two portions of three,
is going to have six carbons.
And if you look
closely, this is really
the fructose 1,6
bisphosphate bound
to the active site of the
enzyme as a Schiff space.
So now all that
needs to happen now
is to hydrolyze the Schiff space
and release our fructose 1,6
bisphosphate product.
So, we're going to need
one water molecule.
It's going to be activated
by a general base.
Then it is going to
attack this imine
and the electrons will
move to the nitrogen.
We get to this step and here
we need a step in catalysis
to regenerate the enzyme
to its freed lysine form
and then release the
fructose 1,6 bisphosphate
product of the reaction.
So once again, we started with
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
and GAP and you used
this covalent catalysis
where the substrates were
bound in the active site
of the enzyme to
form our product,
fructose 1,6 bisphosphate.
Now this, as we discussed
in the carbonyl chemistry,
is an example of
direct adol reaction.
And as the name of
the enzyme suggests,
aldolase this is
the reaction going
in that gluconeogenic mode.
Now in Part B of
the question, we're
going to look at another
important reaction that
can run both ways--
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis.
That will be specifically
going from glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate, or GAP, to
1,3 bisphosphoglycerate.
This is the reaction catalyzed
by GAP dehydrogenase.
Here is a representation
of the reaction.
We have glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate
that is converted by GAP DH to
the 1,3 bisphosphoglycerate.
Now in the glycolysis
step, we know
we need one NAD equivalent,
and one inorganic
phosphate to go into
the enzyme to be
able to oxidize our aldehyde
to an acidic anhydride in 1,3
bisphosphoglycerate.
Now in the
gluconeogenesis, we're
going to be going
from right to left.
We're starting with 1,3
bisphosphoglycerate We're
going to need NADH
and we're going
to generate GAP and
inorganic phosphate.
Now let's take a closer look at
the mechanism of this reaction
as it would run in
gluconeogenesis.
Here we have a representation
of the active site of the GAPDH,
where we highlighted
the cysteine group, SH.
And we also have a general
base in the active site
and we're going to
call it B. And here
is our starting material
1,3 bisphosphoglycerate.
Now if you remember
how GAPDH works
in the direct reaction
in the glycolysis,
we're going to have to form
a covalent intermediate,
in which the substrate is
going to bind to the enzyme.
That's going to form a
thioester with that thiol group
of the cysteine.
So this is what's
going to happen here.
So the base in the
active site actually
is going to assist the
protonation of the cysteine.
Then the thiol now
is activated and can
attack the phosphoanhydride
of the 1,3 biphosphoglycerate.
And then the first
step, it's just
going to form a
tetrahedral intermediate.
There you have it.
Now we have a negative
charge on the oxygen
and we spelled out the phosphate
with all the atoms here.
As you know, this
tetrahedral intermediate
is now going to fall apart,
releasing the best leaving
group.
In this case it is going to
be the inorganic phosphate.
So the electrons come down.
They're going to be
transferred onto the phosphate
and presumably protonated.
So after the
phosphate is released,
now we have formed finally
the thioester of our substrate
in the active site of GAPDH.
As you remember, this
is a redox reaction
so it involves
the co-factor NAD.
In this case, running the
reaction from right to left,
we're going to use NADH to
reduce the bisphosphoglycerate
to the aldehyde group.
So here is our
representation of the NADH.
As you remember, one of
these hydrogens together
with its electron pair,
it's is to be donated
as a hydride or H minus.
So the reaction proceeds by
rearranging the electrons
on the pyradine ring
of NAD and the H minus
is going to be the
nucleophile that's
attacking now the thioester.
And once again, I'm
going to be forming
a tetrahedral intermediate,
which is shown here.
Now this hydride here is
the one that came from NADH.
And in the process
the NADH co-factor
is converted to NAD-plus.
So now we can see we're
just one step away.
This is now like a
hemiacetal like molecule.
So it's one step
away from forming
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
All we need to do is
release the enzyme
in its original confirmation.
So the electrons will flow
now to reform the carbonyl,
while the sulfur is going
to get its electrons
from the base and this
regenerates the enzyme
as we had it in the beginning.
And we're releasing GAP,
the product of the reaction.
So with this
mechanistic insight,
we have actually addressed
how the GAPDH reaction
runs in the gluconeogenic
mode from bisphosphoglycerate
to GAP.
Now Part A of the
problem also asked
us to look up the
free energy value
for the aldolase reaction that
is that delta G naught prime.
Now, if you're going to look
in your favorite chemistry
textbook, or I have here the
Voet and Voet Third Edition,
the book that we
use in this course.
Now you're going to
find on page 511,
you're going to see a table
with all the free energies
of glycolysis reactions.
And for the aldolase
step, you're
going to see that it's a
positive free energy, that
is the reaction is
spontaneous in the reverse
in the gluconeogenic direction.
So now that may be a little
surprising, but keep in mind
that the reactions
in these pathways
are more often
than not, governed
by mass action, that is if we
have an excess of the starting
materials, the reaction would
proceed towards the product,
while if we have an
excess of the products,
the reaction will
proceed backward
towards the starting materials.
So both the aldolase
reaction and the GAP
dehydrogenase reactions
are very susceptible
to this mass action.
So they will be controlled-
the direction, the spontaneity
of this reaction
will be controlled
by which of the starting
materials or products
are in excess.
Part C of this problem
asked us to evaluate
the spontaneity
of gluconeogenesis
at the level of
the whole pathway.
Now we know glycolysis
is a spontaneous process.
Not only when it goes
from glucose to pyruvate,
but also it generates
some high energy
intermediates like
ATP in the process--
like we get two molecules
of ATP per glucose.
Now if we want to go
backwards from pyruvate
to glucose, in a
gluconeogenesis pathway,
can this process be spontaneous?
First let's look at glycolysis.
Here is a schematic
of a glycolysis.
We're starting here
from glucose and we're
going to need a couple
of molecules of ATP
to activate it, to get to
fructose 1,6 bisphosphate.
And from there on,
we're going to generate
actually, two molecules
of ATP at this step
and then two molecules of ATP in
the final pyruvate kinase step.
And of course, we're also going
to need an NAD- plus going
to NADH here at the GAP step.
Well, there's going to be
two of these NAD-plus needed
to oxidize GAP to 1,3
bisphosphoglycerate.
And as we just said, even
though we have some energy cost
in early on, we're actually
generating more ATP
by the time we reach
pyruvate so the pathway is
in fact spontaneous.
Now what about gluconeogenesis.
In gluconeogenesis, we
are starting with pyruvate
and we want to go
back to glucose.
Now if we were to reverse
exactly every single step
in glycolysis, that pathway is
not going to be spontaneous.
Step four in gluconeogenesis
uses these alternate pathways
in a couple of
the steps in order
to make the process spontaneous.
For example, going from
pyruvate to phosphoenolpyruvate
in gluconeogenesis is not a
reverse of the pyruvate kinase
reaction.
It rather occurs in two steps.
So the first step we take
pyruvate and convert it
to oxaloacetate, using
pyruvate carboxylase,
so it's going to need
a molecule of CO2.
And oxaloacetate
has four carbons.
And it's also going
to need energy.
So we're going to need a
molecule of ATP going to ADP.
Now oxaloacetate
can now be processed
inside the
mitochondria or it can
be taken out of the
mitochondria into the cytosol.
And let's say that's the
course of the reaction.
Where it's going to
find an enzyme called
PEP carboxylic
kinase, or PEPCK, that
can take oxaloacetate to PEP.
This enzyme once
again requires energy.
This time in the form
of GTP going to GDP.
And here we're going to
lose that carboxyl group
that we added on earlier.
Now while this might seem
like a cumbersome way
to reverse one reaction,
this allows both the part
of a kinase reaction and
going from pyruvate going back
to PEP, to be controlled
in different ways
and therefore allow
both of these processes
to happen spontaneously.
The rest of gluconeogenesis
will have exactly the reverse
of these steps in glycolsis.
For example, PEP going
to 2-phosphoglycerate.
2-Phosphoglycerate going
to 3-phosphoglycerate.
3-phosphoglycerate going
to 1,3 bisphosphoglycerate.
Here, since in glycolysis
we generated ATP here,
we're going to need the
ATP to come in and go
to ADP in order to accomplish
this step in gluconeogenesis.
1,3 bisphosphoglycerate
going to GAP,
this is the step
we just discussed
in Part 2 of the problem.
As we said, we're going to
need NADH going to NAD-plus.
Then GAP and DHAP going to
fructose 1,6 bisphosphate, this
is the step we discussed in Part
A of this problem, the reverse
of the aldolase reaction.
Now going from fructose 1,6
bisphosphate to glucose,
we're not going to do these
kinase reactions in reverse,
where we would be
generating ATP and therefore
that would be not spontaneous
in the reverse direction.
But rather, we're going to
use alternate enzymes called
phosphatases where we lose the
phosphates without regenerating
an ATP molecules.
So therefore, by
using these two tricks
we can go back to glucose
without regenerating these ATP
molecules, and therefore the
pathway can be spontaneous.
Now the bottom line here
is that both glycolysis
and gluconeogenesis
are spontaneous,
but gluconeogenesis uses most
but not all of the glycolysis
steps to run in reverse.
And while glycolysis
generates energy,
we get a net of 2 molecules
of ATP per molecule of glucose
used, gluconeogenesis as
you guys have seen here,
actually uses energy
to run spontaneously.
That is, we need ATP molecules.
Now if you look
at our diagram, we
need ATP molecules
to convert pyruvate
to phosphoenolpyruvate,
actually 2 of them.
And then we're going
to need more ATP here
to form 1,3 bisphosphoglycerate.
In addition to the
redox, like NADH
co-factor, to run
the GAP dehydrogenase
reaction in reverse.
So given these considerations,
gluconeogenesis
is in fact spontaneous,
but it's going to cost us
several ATP equivalents.
While glycolysis is
spontaneous and generates ATP.
Well, that solves problem
3 of problem set 10.
Here, I hope you got a
better understanding of why
both glycolysis and
gluconeogenesis are
both spontaneous
pathways inside the cell.
Thank you.